- How you feelin' right now?
- I'm so scared
- I'm a little perturbed right now
- It looks terrifying
- It does
- It's just so high
- Just a straightaway
Like we have to go really fast
to be able to get up to that
- So fast, I'm afraid it's not gonna work
- Shit
- Also, I wanna hold on to something
- Hold on to myself, should I just
hold on to myself?
- Oh now there's another one going
I don't know why that makes me more scared
- I know.
Well it's scary because we
haven't seen anyone else
go on this yet
- That's true
- So I know it's gonna be fast but
Okay, they're giving us the signal
- Oh no, oh no
- Hopefully we'll make
it to the other side
If we don't, it's been a good life
- Oh no, oh no, oh no
No no no no
(screaming)
(fast-paced electronic music)
Whoo!
- Oh my god, what did we just do?
- Are you crying?
- I'm crying a little bit
- Oh my god, my heart
- I feel like I just had a midlife crisis
What did we just do?
- I feel born again
- Yeah, a little bit
Oh man
- That first 10 seconds
- Is the most terrifying
like I've never felt less control
- No!
I felt like I was dying
- Oh man, I felt like
I was dying repeatedly
- Seriously
I've never felt anything like that
- That's entertainment, though
- Yeah, I was very entertained
- Oh, we're gonna look so dumb
How dumb did we look?
- I'm sure we looked incredibly dumb